I wanted to talk to you a lot about
engines uh and maybe about Starship and
maybe about your own becoming an actual
astronaut but like let's just go there
uh before all that and and talk about
the actual culture of SpaceX and uh your
conversations with uh Elon you've toured
SpaceX facilities with him you've
interviewed him you've interacted with
him
uh what have you learned about Rockets
about propulsion about engineering about
design about life from those
interactions he's pretty transparent
open human being as an engineer as a as
a leader as a person
I would definitely say the biggest
takeaway I've had from my times with
Elon at SpaceX is
real like the the idea of questionnaire
constraints he says that a lot but he
also does it a lot like he though you
know there'll be times where like
you'll see him change on a dime because
he's like rethinking of something in a
newer different way and for me you know
I I think we all put constraints on
ourselves we think about our own limits
you know on
on things that we can or cannot do and I
think it's made me kind of question like
well why am I why did I say no I can't
do that or you know uh you know just off
the top of my head a good example uh I
so in Iowa I live in Iowa or half the
time or whatever and uh there's a bike
right across the state of Iowa called
Ragbrai and every year you just you know
like thousands of people get together
and they they ride across Iowa and it
was last summer I met up with some
friends and like hey you want to go on
ragbra this year I'm like it's like a
week away they're like yeah you want to
go I'm like yeah and so I did without
and it was one of those moments where I
was proud of myself because it's like I
it's easy to just be like no you know
I'm not ready or this is my constraint
is like I'm not in shape but like just
question that you know and and so I
think when it comes down to questioning
your own constraints it's yes even to
that level like why do you question
yourself on what you can and cannot do
so that's for your personal life is
really powerful but a little bit more
intuitive I think what's really hard is
to question constraints in a place like
Aeronautics or or robotics or autonomous
vehicles or Vehicles because there's
people there's experts everywhere that
have done it for decades and everyone
admires those experts and respects those
experts and you for you to step into a
room and knowing not much more than just
uh what's in a Wikipedia article yeah
and to just use your intuition and first
principles thinking to disagree with the
experts that takes uh that takes some uh
guts I think well you can't have
everyone doing that either you know like
there has to be some humility of knowing
that something is a hardened concept and
a hard you know like especially I'm not
an engineer I don't I don't do this
stuff you know but I can imagine you
sitting there having spent six years on
a type of valve that perfectly manages
crowdog propellants or whatever and
someone walks in and says why don't you
just put a heater element in there you
know or something that's you know
something like because probably you know
we've done that 40 times whatever
whatever you know like I'm sure there
are things like that that are very
frustrating but but I know what that's
like you know the thing is with the
experts they're always going to be
frustrated
when the Newbie comes in with their
first principles thinking but sometimes
that frustration is Justified and
sometimes it's not sometimes just
stubbornness for failing to acknowledge
a better way and I've seen it both
directions so which is really
interesting so you need you need both
but that tension is always going to be
there and there has to be a almost like
a dictatorial uh imperative that breaks
through the the expertise of the way
things have been been done in the past
to push forward like a new way of doing
it and elon's done that um I've seen a
lot of great Engineers uh do that in the
Machining machine learning world because
there's been so much Development I've
seen that happen usually when there's
like rapid development that starts to
come into play yeah and yeah and I've
seen that autonomous vehicle space
um bringing computer interfaces that
Elon has evolved with all of it it's
kind of fascinating to watch
um what about the actual design and
Engineering of the engine since you've
learned about so many different kinds of
engines
over the past few years
just like what stands out to you about
the way that engineering is done at
SpaceX or that Elon does engineering
the hardest thing to
kind of remember is like how much stuff
was developed in the 50s and 60s you
know the the concepts finally being
utilized today were already literally
done in the 60s yeah you know so a lot
of the things that SpaceX is doing isn't
a novel concept per se you know they're
like for instance the Raptor engine
utilizes the full flow stage combustion
cycle engine
and that was already developed by the
Soviets in the 60s for an engine called
the rd270 and it's makes sense like on
paper 100 it makes sense because you're
basically extracting the absolute
maximum
potential of the chemical energy in both
propellants and you know at the at the
end of the day like you have to be dumb
enough to say we're going to try using
this thing because it's actually really
complicated to to do what they're doing
but at the same time like so are Rockets
like rocket engines are already stupid
complicated so adding you know 10 20
more you know pain in the butt during
the r d if it's you know in the long
long long 20 30 year existence or
whatever you know like future of that
engine is that going to be worth it
obviously SpaceX said yeah I think we
can actually develop this this Raptor
engine
so it's just interesting to see the
things that have been looked at or even
reusability you know like the space
shuttle was reusable it was fully uh the
upper stage you know the shuttle itself
the Orbiter was you know I mean that
thing was for all intents and purposes a
reusable rocket
now did it live up to its expectations
not necessarily so it left a lot of bad
taste in people's mouth on the the ideas
of reusability so for SpaceX to kind of
come back into the room and on the table
and say we're going to use the reusable
rocket specifically we're going to do a
fully reasonable rocket you know a lot
of people are even still the day a lot
of people going yeah you're not gonna be
able to do that
even today even today so like long term
you're not gonna be able to reuse a
scale
yeah but yeah definitely I think the
number of people that are saying that
today is is a small portion of those
that were saying that type of thing five
years ago you know when Elon did that
announcement in 2016
um for the its it was very very
aspirational and people were just like
yeah right you know and there's a large
number of people that had the factual
reasons to to think that and do that you
know um at the time they'd only landed
like two Rockets or something you know
when they did that or maybe three it was
a very small number uh when they
announced that actually they had just
lost a couple months prior they just
lost mo6 so they like they were still
this young blossoming company and they
come in and be like we figured out
reusability and now we're gonna go full
scale make the world's biggest most
heaviest most powerful rocket ever and
we're going to fully reuse it and it's
gonna go to Mars but it's just
pretty out there like it really was and
oh yeah you know it's all about
perspective but now again we're coming
up on 100 consecutive Landings of an
orbital class rocket that's you know 45
meters tall 3.7 meters wide like this
thing is huge weighs 20 metric tons even
empty when it's Landing
that thing's already huge so seeing the
success of that I think people are now
more like well okay maybe maybe there is
actually
the opportunity to be fully reusable
that's definitely probably the biggest
constraint that I think has been
questioned that is yep and then of
course like the broader one of cost of
bringing down costs
that he's able to you're able to kind of
bring down costs so much the this
something like colonizing Mars our many
trips to Mars will be a possibility
because yeah people don't even it seems
so far out that they don't even have
time or give effort to questioning it
yeah but it's the implied questioning
can you really do that many launches
actually do it can you actually do it
yeah it's looking I think it's one of
those things where you look at the curve
you know you look at like 10 years ago
that was ridiculous yeah following this
curve if SpaceX goes from you know two
years ago launching I don't remember
what it was 40 times to 60 times to 100
times this year is there is there amount
and if we just keep extrapolating that
out if they maybe not that exponential
maybe it goes more linear or whatever
what's 20 30 years like the amount of
stuff we can put on orbit and and the
potential we have to do things like
absolutely now I don't want to put a
time frame like you know yeah I think
but you gotta think it's it we're
increasingly number of launches we're
increasing the amount of things in space
we're increasing the amount of payload
on orbit that's probably not going to
decrease anytime soon and therefore
eventually like the idea of going to
Mars is absolutely reasonable